exactement six mois après
vaccinations j'ai des titres protecteurs
abandonné et les experts recommandés
effectuer la procédure de revaccination que moi et
fait il y a quelques jours d'abord
fait cette vidéo d'injection le lendemain
après une conversation avec ils n'ont pas osé qu'il
Au fait, je ne l'ai pas fait moi-même
la deuxième partie de cette procédure, à savoir
c'est cette poudre qu'elle a nasalisée
c'est ce que c'est c'est juste
aussi une seringue seulement au lieu de liquide
substances
a marqué la poudre m'a demandé
respirez profondément sur trois
soufflé d'un côté à l'autre
15 minutes je me suis ensuite assis et c'est tout
fini aucun sentiment honnêtement
disant que je n'avais pas
juste rien juste assis pendant 15 minutes et
allé aujourd'hui après ces deux procédures
injection et cette forme initiale de la seconde
parties j'ai déjà fait du sport aujourd'hui